I want you to live the life you were
meant to live you hear me not the life
that was given to you people have big
dreams but you don't act on them when
you're feeling bold and confident and
then when the boldness and the
confidence slips from you you never take
action don't chase something because
people have told you that you should
want it literally just look at what
gives you more energy than it takes
what's exciting for you
rise and shine it's and spresso time
what's up believe nation it's evan i
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message have big dreams
over to you eric thomas also if you want
to know what Eric Thomas and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in the description below
even if you've my closest friend I have
boundaries if you won't get to the next
level you're gonna have to give up
something right what I've been telling
you to get that gold get that dream and
I'm just been telling you driving and
driving and driving and driving what
I've been talking about is consistency
[Music]
I want you to live the life you were
meant to live you hear me
not the life that was given to you I'm a
high school dropout cuz that's the life
my daddy gave me but I've been married
almost 28 years and two kids by the same
woman which is not my experience
I got brothers and sisters none of us
had the same parents because I made it
with my mind
that's the life y'all gave me I'm not
I'm not taking that no more I don't want
I don't want to be on crack I've never
drank I never smoked and I'm not against
it I just didn't do it because my family
was doing it and they weren't winning
doing it uncle died of cirrhosis of the
liver I'm like bruh I'm not going out
like that
uncle's in prison I'm not going I wasn't
meant to be in prison I got married at
19 y'all's meant to live with a woman
I'm not I'm not
ain't mad actually bruh I'm just being
real it's some dudes they like I'm
hardcore I'm not hard I promise you I'm
not hard I want to be with no dudes all
day everyday nah I'm gonna need a break
I'm gonna need a break from that I'm
just being real I'm gonna need a break
for me and my man in the same bunk and I
ain't got no privacy I'm gonna need a
break from that I'm just being real I'm
gonna need a break from prison food imma
need my grandma cooking at some point
I'm just being real just be honest when
you walk out of here
some of you are not transitioning
because you're okay with the life you
have and I'm telling you right when I
walk out I want to be an example of you
can start from wherever and get to
wherever you want to get to that's what
I'm asking you to do what fuse you the
reason why you so lazy is not because
you don't have the ability you so lazy
because your dreams so small I think
people have big dreams but you don't act
on them when you're feeling bold and
confident and then when the boldness and
the confidence slips from you you never
take action and so you might be only
bold and confident 1% of your life and
that's a time when you come up with
these amazing dreams and you think that
you can actually do it but then you wake
up the next day and that boldness and
confidence poof it disappeared and so
you need to act on the thing that you
want to do act on the dream when you are
feeling bold and confident quick example
came back from vid summit it's a YouTube
event in Los Angeles put on by Derral
Eve's
tons of fun and I spent four straight
days pretty much waking up at 7:30 going
to the lobby
hanging out with entrepreneurs helping
them pushing them moving them crying
with them until 2:30 in the morning and
then I woke up the next day and did it
again did it again did it again for four
straight days and I had a fever the
whole time I was barely eating not go to
the washroom forgetting to take breaks
and it was not healthy it was not
healthy but it was amazing it was
amazing for me because I filled me up I
knew that I had to do more of it so
here's what happened this is I think
what happens to so many entrepreneurs
I'm on the plane I'm about to go home
and said I need to find a way to keep
doing this I can't do it in the way that
I'm doing it now because this is not
healthy or sustainable I will I will
pass out on the floor but I have to find
a way to keep doing it and so I thought
I'm gonna start an Instagram live
morning show not just doing it on the
phone when there's somebody tuning in
with me but like face to face I want to
do a morning show five days a week at my
studio at Toronto dancehall so I have
somebody with me face to face and I'm
helping I want I want that feeling every
single morning helping an individual out
it makes me come alive but here this is
what happened I get on the plane I come
up with the idea and I love it I'm
feeling bold I'm feeling confident had
four days of Awesomeness and then with
every passing chunk of time 10 minutes
later 20 minutes later 30 minutes later
after come with the idea I feel myself
slipping away from that idea I feel
myself losing momentum I feel myself
instead of being 100% sure I want to do
it down to 95 94 93 92 it's ticking its
ticking with every pass in ten minutes
another percent is ticking is ticking
off it's ticking off is ticking off and
I'm losing the confidence and I'm losing
the boldness and I'm flying back to
Toronto I'm saying I don't need yeah I
don't know do I really need to do that
and I felt the momentum sucking out of
the situation this is so important for
entrepreneurs because you feel bold you
feel confident you make a decision you
make a choice in your most powerful most
bold state of all time and then it's
gonna start slipping slip
sipping sipping sipping sipping and when
you feel that momentum being sucked out
of your idea you have to take action to
commit to somebody else and so the thing
that I did on the airplane was I started
committing to the people on my team I
met like 80% now 80% sure I want to do
it I feel slipping by me every minute
slipping by me and start email the
people on my team I email Alex an email
Lily a mental Jay Rhys
I emailed Danny I'm overhearing email
all the people who scheduled this
involves because if I have to do a 9:00
a.m. show every day that's gonna mess up
a lot of people's schedules and the
thing that's running in the back of my
head is I don't have time to do this
this is not a smart thing to do right
now I'm trying to launch my next book
I'm trying to launch my 90 day tour of
the US like I've got a lot of stuff on
my plate and I do not have the time for
this I just came back from two weeks of
being away and I'm behind on every
project every possum behind I do not
have time for this and yet I have to do
it because it comes from here every
major decision needs to be led from your
heart and not your head and so I'm
emailing everybody on my team and I'm
telling them under symbol when you want
to start this and this is Friday night
I'm coming back at midnight oh I'm
certain Monday like ASAP right away then
I start emailing guests I have nobody
booked for this show I start connect
with people who are in my city and said
hey I'm starting this new show do you
want to be my first guest on Monday hey
I'm starting this new show you want even
our next guest on Tuesday I'd line up
the first week of shows to force myself
to do it because I was in the moment
feeling bold in confidence I felt it
slipping
I felt the momentum going away and I
have to commit to somebody else and so I
think that happens to so many
entrepreneurs I think that happens to
you all the time something happens that
inspires greatness inside you that makes
you feel bold and confident unstoppable
and you want to go off and do something
big with it and you you make a plan and
you believe it
but in every passing hour you lose a
little bit of momentum you lose a little
bit more confidence to the point where
for me when I got back when I was just
about to go on and do my first show I
had zero interest in doing it because my
head had taken over again because if you
said Evan you should do this show you
should do this like not I mean it makes
sense for teach eclis yeah it makes
but like I got just got too much stuff
to do until I did my first show and then
it sparked back up holy cow is amazing
this is why I do it now remember you got
to get out of your own way and so I'm
gonna give you a three step process to
prevent this from happening to you ever
again number one put yourself in a
position to feel bold and confident
whatever the thing is it helps you feel
bold and confident put yourself in that
position and that may be something and
you can access on the regular but for
most people it's hard to get in that
position every single day at a huge high
and so what I highly recommend is
actually trying to find something that
is outside your comfort zone that is
different from your usual so that's
where me going to vid summit make a big
difference that's where when I go to a
Tony Robbins event it makes a big
difference that's when people come to my
event they're there in an insane state
they're all pumped up they're all
feeling bold and confident around people
who support them the workshop that I do
twice a year here in Toronto like when
you come you become a different person
for those three days that you're with me
you become a different person become the
best most bold most confident version of
yourself you will believe in your
abilities and capabilities more than you
have ever in your life that's what we
bring out in the workshop people think
is just a how-to YouTube or chop you
will anyway it's amazing but like put
yourself in that position where you feel
bold and confident and unstoppable sign
up for a workshop go to a course if you
can't afford that then then whatever the
thing is that makes you feel bold on top
of all in confidence you're in that
mindset now you're feeling unstoppable
you could do anything awesome
step to make a plan make a plan make a
plan for your life make a plan for your
business make a plan for where you're
gonna go make a plan make a plan make a
plan look imagine what you want to be
working on the thing that makes you come
alive because now you're feeling bold
and on top of all confident you're gonna
start to actually believe that plan when
you remove the limits you when you
remove the limits of your mind of what
you tell yourself you're not capable of
doing it's a magical world you just live
in there enough make a plan and then
step number three commit to someone else
before you lose momentum as soon as you
get on the airplane as soon as you leave
my workshop as soon
that song finishes playing soon as that
concert is over as soon as that thing
that event that make you feel so bold
and confident is over tick tick tick
tick tick momentum starts being sucked
out of you minute by minute second my
second you know hour by hour it starts
being sucked out of you and so while
you're still in there when you feel the
momentum being sucked out of you you're
still in there commit to somebody else
commit to as many people as possible
tell them here's what I'm doing this is
my new plan if especially with impacts
them in some way or recruit them to join
you because those bonds because you'll
let yourself down all day long you will
let yourself down on your dreams all day
long but when you commit to somebody
else and you say I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna show up I'm gonna be at that gym
I'm gonna be there for the interview I'm
gonna be there for you I'm gonna be
there we're gonna do this thing together
when you commit to somebody else you're
way less likely to let somebody else
down and so those social bonds hold you
to doing the thing that you said you
were gonna do when you're feeling bold
and unstoppable because it is possible
because it's entirely possible but
what's gonna happen is you are gonna get
in your own way you will get in your own
way as soon as you leave that bold
confident state it's important it's
powerful I think people have big dreams
they just don't know how to live up to
them because they don't believe in them
enough and that's a process to do it so
put yourself in that state of really
bold unstoppable powerful to make a
plane and in three commit to somebody
else now I've got a really special bonus
clip that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that time for question of the day
I want to know what is the thing that
helps make you feel old
unstoppable confident is it going to a
workshop as a playing music like what's
the thing that gets you all fired up I
want to know leaving the comments below
Tom I think my goal may be too big
anybody else gonna chime in on that one
I write it every day but it makes me
feel heavy daunted and terrified to
pursue it rather than excited okay
that's powerful have I chosen my goal
poorly or or do I need to man up okay
the dude Brian I love you so much for
this question in in this question is
like everything that people go through
so first of all your goal is not too big
okay
you're just not yet the person you need
to be to execute against that and that
is absolutely fine
I'm not yet the person I need to be in
order to rival Disney I know that and so
every day I'm waking up not saying am i
there yet am i there yet am i there yet
I'm thinking what's one really simple
thing that I could do right now today to
learn something that moves me down that
path or who can i partner with you know
what's the idea that I need to get other
people excited about what I'm doing so
that's super important so your dream is
never too big even if you said you want
to terraform Mars I'm with you right
that's our boy Elon Musk is literally
thinking about that so your dream isn't
too big you just don't think about like
the end goal and let it overwhelm you
which is what is happening to you you're
riding it every day okay so you're
obsessing about that end goal that end
outcome which first of all if that end
outcome is about a thing like the thing
that I think about every day is not
building a studio to rival Disney even
though that's often what I externalize
to people what I think about internally
the thing that warms my soul is I think
about the people out there that are
extraordinary they could do something
amazing with their lives but they won't
because they don't believe in themselves
so what I think about the thing that
drives me that obsesses me and fills me
with excitement and joy to get good
enough to actually do it is helping
people develop an empowering mindset
that's my obsession the whole rival
Disney thing is a path and I think it's
the right path and I'm excited to do it
and I love it but at the end of the day
the thing that keeps me going when I'm
feeling overwhelmed is helping other
people so figure out what that thing is
that huge goal that you have why you
want it because chances are that you're
going to be able to do it in smaller
ways along the way as well so
it's not like this you know 20-year
chasm of binary nothingness where you're
not at all doing what you want to do and
then suddenly one day it either happens
or it doesn't like you know winning the
lottery that it's you know these
incremental steps okay so you write it
down every day start writing down the
the beautiful thing you want to bring
into the world and also even that like
you should be spending time what are you
grateful for right now thinking about
what you want to learn thinking about
things that excite you it makes you feel
heavy daunted and terrified to pursue it
okay
so if it makes you feel heavy daunted
and terrified to pursue it because
you're obsessing over the end goal it's
some like traditional marker of success
money and big company whatever and not
how you want to help people then it's
just a matter of reframing if on the
other hand is because you think you're
supposed to want that thing but you
don't actually want it and so the idea
of pursuing it and all you would have to
do to get there is just horrifying to
you then yes you've picked the wrong
goal only you can answer that question I
have no idea which of the two is true
just remember don't chase something
because people have told you that you
should want it literally just look at
what gives you more energy than it takes
what's exciting for you raise your
standard cool its core value not one
drop of my self-worth depends on your
it's something serene if you want more
Eric Thomas check out the top fifty
rules video that I made on him it's
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there you will not work me Oh
Joe jet you will not work me and your
Bentley you will not work me